war richtig heiß und dieses komplette
hotel wurde einfach mit einem funky
command blog ist und ich komme da
überhaupt nicht darauf klar
v
münchen meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft gemeinsamen freien
übrigens vor ihr falls ihr hier so licht
und hier auf meinem hals sind das kein
tattoo das wer denkt dass das in tattoo
es luca die sonne kommt halt genau
dadurch deswegen hab ich denke das passt
mit dem licht wir befinden uns hier in
einer weiteren folge der minecraft guck
mal ich hab mir wieder 3,1 ausgesucht
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr bis zum
ende dran wenn ihr coole commands kennt
oder so einfach und in die kommentare
schreiben
dann sehe ich die und genau wir fangen
an mit dem ersten command wir geben
wieder ein / gfp command unterstrich
blog damit wir den schönen command blog
bekommen ok zu deutsch befiehlt block
setzen hinsetzen ein hebel daneben und
der erster command füge ich direkt mal
schon mal ein
der wurde mir nehme ich nicht zugesendet
aber den habe ich gefunden bei crash
pixel und zwar das der meteoriten
command im meteoriten command fügt hinzu
wie er ist glaube ich selbst schon sagt
meteoriten und zwar drücke ich einfach
drauf hier kommt wieder so eine kleine
kuhle command blogs aktiv alle aus dem
himmel runter ist das erst mal richtig
aufgefallen und jetzt seht ihr schon
dass im chat ordentlich ausgelastet wird
und wir können jetzt ganz easy ich hier
auf click to get to spawn alten clique
und wir bekommen 64 meter getaucht sind
das sind glaube ich eigentlich
tintenfischs paul meier allerdings wenn
ich jetzt damit ganz simpler kommentar
mal wieder als erstes einfach auf den
boden draufsteht ich schon dass
wirklichen der tintenfisch kommt
der meteorit
fakt ist ich habe schon gesehen ich habe
nach vorne eigentlich hingekriegt und
der sport hier dass das bond halt
einfach nur so ein bisschen im umkreis
das heißt ich kann ja auch quasi mal
ganz viele ich hier hinsetzen also genau
hierhin wenn ich jetzt nach oben schaue
die vielen halt alle so umkreis dahin
allerdings nie direkt okay jetzt liegen
sie doch ein bisschen direkt dahin aber
da vorne sind auf welche irgendwie
explodiert oder hier vorne und die
richten hat allemal sein gewissen radius
an wie keine ahnung also die sie richten
keinen radius an sondern sie richten
einen gewissen
die sind halt sowie mehrere tiere hier
auf einmal das heißt ich letztes quasi
hin wir können das jetzt mal beobachten
jetzt kommt der meteor jeden moment von
unten
er knallt dort runter und ich würde
sagen dass hinzu naja kommen wir
vergleichen es einfach mal mit einem tnt
ich meine ich kann er hier rein
theoretisch einfach mal einen tee hinten
setzen einen hebel drauf dass tnt schön
anzünden und dann sehen wir schon der
radius von tnt explosion schaden ist
viel kleiner als das also ich würde
sagen das ist so sicher wie 56 tnt oder
irgendwie so mahnt ist von quatsch pixel
ich glaube ich mache mir meine neue map
weil hier die ganze zeit irgendwas im
chat steht aber wir sehen uns dann jetzt
bei comand nummer zwei jeder in meiner
neuen welt so die neue welt wird hier
gerade erstellt wow dem rap skillz welt
erstellt nein schrägstrich gfp command
unterstrich block und ich habe wieder
meinen command block dann nehme ich mir
hier wieder einen schönen hebel und der
nächste command ist nämlich von der
rennjury und zwar fügt er einen
parachute beziehungsweise fallschirm zu
deutsch hinzu das ist auch schon super
dass ich jetzt hier eine neue welt hat
uns wach springe ich dann einfach von da
oben gleich mal direkt runter und sporne
hier erst mal ganz kurz den command und
zwar ist der command sehr sehr lange ich
geb den hier eine brücke ganz kurz
setzte den schalter daneben und ihr seht
schon das board sich hier von der
engineer von dem hatten wir auch schon
manchmal komme es dabei übrigens sehr
viele leute dass die serie einfach nur
jazz commands besteht deswegen versuche
ich jetzt in den nächsten folgen nicht
so viele sachen von inter zu nehmen
obwohl ich ja dann glaube ich gar nichts
gegen hat also ich meine erfahrung ist
immer meine tweets er kommt immer die
videos also ich denke nicht dass er da
was gegen hat allerdings haben viele
bemängelt ordens stolz da nur die von
edge of arabia
also ich find's cool er macht super
sachen
er macht derzeit auch subs wie sonstwas
und ich find's cool aber dann nehme ich
in den nächsten folgen bei sachen von
paar anderen ihr habt schon gesehen ich
habe jetzt gerade dieses schild hier
gedrückt und wir sehen im chat drop on
ground lasertechnik ist ring and above
any color das heißt letter to nick da
können wir einfach hier diese leder
brust platte also leder tunika nehmen
dann nehmen wir einfach einen wie heißt
das ganze ding noch mal das heißt faden
genau einfahren war das und noch einen
banner einer beliebigen farbe ich nehme
jetzt einfach mal hellblau das ist
eigentlich ein ganz coole farbe und dann
können wir das zu dritt einfach ganz
easy auf dem boden hier spalten dann
sehen wir schon knapp wir bekommen einen
parachute den können uns auch ganz easy
dann anziehen dann haben wir nämlich
hier sondern so eine pinke tunika mehr
oder weniger auf und wenn ich
dementsprechend jetzt mit diesem
fallschirm irgendwo runterspringen sage
ich mal jetzt im game 1 0
das ist ganz gut dass wird es in der
neuen welt hier oben sondern seinen
coolen punkt haben gehe ich einfach mal
den gamern 0 springe dort runter schaut
nach oben und rücke ein paarmal er und
dann werde ich schon bin ich hier im
falschen modus und quandt quasi mit
einem falschen natürlich ist ruckelt ein
bisschen usw
es ist wie gesagt nur ein command aber
kann hiermit ganz easy landen und das
zieht noch gar kein leben hab also ich
bin ja gerade von relativ weit oben
runter gesprungen und ihr seht schon ein
falsches paket schon diese anzeige die
ich recht habe ist verschwunden mein
fallschirm habe ich zwar immer noch an
aber ich habe noch so ein leder hier in
der im inventar herumflattern was aber
ich konnte auf jeden fall landen ohne
dass sich irgendwelchen fall schaden
genommen hat trotz dessen ich im gaylord
0 war also ich bin von da oben wir unter
gesprungen bin hier vorne irgendwie
gelandet das ist ganz cool ist noch
verbesserungswürdig aber dafür dass es
nun command ist es das mega live das
vakuum an nummer 2 von barrett engineer
und wie kommen schon direkt zu command
nummer drei diesmal kann sein dass ich
heute mega schnell durch kommen
irgendwie leicht liegt am guten wetter
hier sind kann 31 grad draußen
dann gehe ich da auch gleich mal okay
wir machen weiter roman nummer drei ist
von super trouper hans fans gegen dich
aber wie bist du auf den gottverdammten
namen gekommen ist ein deutscher
youtuber der sich diesen command
ausgedacht hat und zwar füge ich den
hier ein und jetzt das unternehmen das
ist es was er ab ich so ein bisschen
aber da ich will das gar nicht irgendwie
kritisieren oder irgendwie sowas weil es
mega es ist was dieser command hinzufügt
das ganze dauert zwar so ein bisschen im
vergleich zu kommen von anderen leuten
jetzt haben wir allerdings schon dass
sportec hier im inventar und zwar create
hotel ja ihr habt richtig gelesen ich
kann mit diesem spot ein komplettes
hotels vorne das heißt ich setze es
beispielsweise mal einfach hier dieses
diesen zeiten dahin damit habe ich jetzt
quasi das schaf getötet und jetzt bond
hier ein hotel das dauert ein bisschen
das ist jetzt nicht so zac instinkt und
das ist da sondern wir haben hier lag da
haben wir front was genau hat und dann
haben wir hier auf jeden fall erstmal so
das erste stockwerk und da dachte ich
erst dass es nur bei dem stockwerk er
bleibt allerdings dauert das ein
bisschen und zwar dann habe ich dann
gedacht so das ist jetzt alles so ist
war schon nice aber da kommt da nicht
noch mehr und dann hab ich irgendwie
hier noch was hingesetzt und dachte dann
so hey da muss auch irgendwie mehr
kommen auf dem zum teil das auch noch
nach mehr aus wie ok jetzt ist sogar
etwas gespannt also das meinte ich
vorhin mit
dann hab ich da einfach mal was
hingesetzt und jetzt seht ihr schon
jetzt ist das ganze ding nämlich was ich
war grade dauerhaftes nicht obwohl ich
nicht gedrückt habe jetzt ist das ganze
ding nämlich fertig wo sich das dann
aussieht schon da unten sportdirektors
dann weil es dort recht dunkel drin ist
allerdings so groß ist das alles also
früher ging's dann nur bis hier
irgendwie so in etwa und jetzt ist das
ganze ja auch noch gekommen
muss man ihm ein paar blöcke draufsetzen
das ganze funktioniert wir haben auch
verschiedene zimmer hier haben wir das
so eingerichtet damit so eingerichtet
damit beispielsweise noch im bett einer
ecke stehen wo wir hier im crafting
table haben und nichts das ist auf jeden
fall richtig nice also wirklich ein
hotel mit lobby und mit mit teppich und
einzelnen zimmern und was weiß ich also
gar nicht reingehen dass mein zimmer
sieht aus wie so ein ballermann hotel wo
man einfach nur auf mallorca ist um
party zu machen oder irgendwie so ist
aber richtig nice und dieses komplette
hotel wurde einfach mit einem funky
command blog ist und ich komme da
überhaupt nicht darauf klar ist es
einfach so krass was man mittlerweile
minecraft alles machen kann auch seitdem
ich mit peterle vor ein paar tagen
mario kart racing aufgenommen das war
linke ich euch mal da irgendwo da ist
das verlinkt seitdem ich das mit peter
aufgenommen hat denke ich mir echt sowas
ist aus minecraft geworden im positiven
sinne richtig krass was die modding und
command szene aus diesem spiel heraus
holt das ist unfassbar dass sich und
sorry das ich jetzt hier so emotional
euphorisch werde
sorry das war es auf jeden fall mit
command nummer drei und dementsprechend
auch mit der command blogs mit der
komanis folge für heute wenn es euch wie
immer mal gefallen hat euch die arbeit
was ich die command et cetera ich fühle
mich definitiv bei einer bewertung
freuen wird oft vernachlässigt da
schauen die leute dass sie die an und
denken sich im buch also müsst ihr auch
nicht eigentlich geht doch einfach raus
spielen das mache ich jetzt auch ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr demnächst
auch noch mal mit dabei sein